okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is one of an infinite
series of meetings about language
completeness and consistency for Wolfram
language and our first topic for today
is the icon eyes function and new design
for it okay so should we look at this
design here
I should be accessing this let's see is
there a problem with the internal site
here I know there we go okay so talk us
through this billion so I'm not Billy
but I met with Billy to look at this
before the meeting so I can speak to
this so the first question we have as
openers on the left or right and so we
have sort of two examples of things one
is the right this community graph plot
which is a list and my graph which is a
name thing and then on one of so the
only difference between the one series
and the two series is open or left or
right and yes Jeremy Davis what do you
think about this I'd liked it left well
so so opener right icon left was my
preference
yeah I think Billy started with the
other side because we have this for
summary boxes and there's an argument to
stay consistent there versus entities
which open too I think but I kind of
prefer to move everything to the right
including summary boxes you mean this
one here this yeah you know kind of like
that cuz you just lead with the unique
thing as opposed to leading with a plus
sign so I kind of like leading with the
you know the identity of the blob yes
well the other hands if it's on the left
then it's always in the same place and
you don't have the
a variable wit Singh shoving it over it
doesn't know this design doesn't shove
anything over its you know it expands
but stays in the same spot yes the end
of the mouse yep really well you can see
you have a - look oh I see I'm sorry I
was standing the wrong way yes if I go
from up to down and yes no what I meant
is that you know if you look at my graph
equals marvel universe graph you know I
I have you know when it's on the Left
the plus is always I understand what
you're saying there's always in a fixed
location relative to the beginning of
the box but so what I mean the in the
other case is in a fixed location
relative to the end of the box right so
we're not going to have the the opener
right aligned okay I guess yeah we
looked at that that seemed like what we
do and then it's like obvious you don't
want to be jumping back and forth with
your mouse to the toggle
um well so how does this relate to other
things I mean what's another example of
something that that has a plus like this
I mean is this some so do sparse array
of 1 2 3 or entity I think or no entity
doesn't there's something like entity it
would that has a plus Billy what
implicit entity classes like yeah okay
yeah largest countries yeah actually I
would agree the putting I mean could we
could we get a mock-up of this on the
right I agree that this might look
better on the right especially when
you're ganging it up with you I I really
never like that conflict of the to it
and feel much better on the right fine I
mean what happens in this multi you know
double-decker thing yeah Billy had a
designee we think it may be topped right
that's like that sounds right yeah okay
and let's let's look at the implicit
entity so you're saying entity of
country arrow population arrow largest
three or something yeah take largest
three oh well that is on the right yeah
it's much heavy you know it's a little
too heavy but other than that you know
position wise it makes sense
okay so uniform izing this sounds like a
good idea I mean it moves but not for a
good reason I think there's some weird
formatting issue going on with a slight
movement right in summary boxes I mean
there isn't a guarantee that the thing
up top is the same when you open it and
that that level well I mean we can
always just decide I see what you're
saying it could be that the overall box
gets wider for example right ooh
that's ugly well maybe I mean you could
imagine edge case where that's horrible
with lots of padding in the closed form
yeah sure which is not that that's not
right yeah yeah so if you look at like
compiled function must be library
function just started a rough page
that's lightly yeah that one could get
wider right and well okay clearly not
thinking of the right but there are
cases where we sort of you know in the
closed form we truncate but then in the
in the open form we allow like a file
name so like if this library function
this has a function name rather than the
function name rather than the file name
but for example if you had the file name
we limit the width but then in the open
state we allow you to see the full file
okay so hold on think that's true of the
lines at the top or that's true only add
lines further down that is true of lines
at the top
ugly ugly ugly that is okay when we open
up my list of summary boxes yeah I don't
know I don't see how to solve that one
but let's yeah I mean look I really hate
the fact that we've got icon icon going
on here yeah and that we couldn't do it
in that entity case because it would
looked horrible the plus sign is
overshadowing the little you know the
down arrow yeah um okay well let's let's
take a look all right let's go back to
Billy's design over here so is there a
tinge of blue in your is there this is a
kind of a cold gray with a slight blue
tinge is that right Billy it's Billy
here he's here his audio yes what was
the answer the question is the question
there is a tinge of blue in there and
you could open up a new tab and change
the 1 to a 2 for the URL and you could
sort of see a comparison or the link is
in your notebook on the Left link on the
left okay Steve and I've just pasted it
in an example of that truncation versus
opening in case god I can hardly see the
difference in the blue right but the
blue looks better I think yeah yeah we
like the blue better it's really subtle
so I think it achieves the you know make
it stand out less
you
what were you asking me to do link
launch first of dark command-line what
is this shared work and just like for me
that said open after horrifying error
message could you please note down that
error message and why don't you just
send a screen capture of what it looks
like all right um okay let's look at
these
so there's plus minus vs. Chevron's I
think I prefer plus minus yeah we kind
of really wanted to unify everything so
we can get one you know opener method
and apply it everywhere in the same spot
that's where we wanted to get to yeah I
agree with that okay so now I'm going
back to this this uh nikon eyes business
so that only shows up in when it's in
the open view right yeah yeah I think
Billy had a version where it wasn't but
I really don't think you wanted oh you
don't want to exposed yeah um can we go
a little lighter with the dot dot dots
here yeah um
someone on our livestream is saying that
this horrifying error message happens
when the application name has spaces in
it on the Mac with link launched that is
truly horrifying truly truly horrifying
and I appreciate somebody out there
knows that well oh there does look look
at that it has a space so all right so
if you just added this you know
quotes around it but I'm about to send
you there okay
in case the sushma can you report that
please Wow horrifying horrifying bug
from deep in the entrails of the
creature and one of those weird things
that's probably different between wolf
and desktop and other applications
because wolf and desktop happens to have
a space in its name now I've run into
this sort of thing regularly because
I've renamed my app bundles to have
spaces and it's a right pain in the butt
well by the way it's something for QA to
know that they should test with things
renamed to have spaces in them okay
in any case um I think the dots should
go maybe gray uh they could go the same
size but a little grayer this dataset
icon is weird I don't see this really
well what is this I should be the main
thing yeah okay so it should be image 3d
talk talk yeah okay and then right and
the one thing I question oh he made two
errors so the suggested alternate was
that we should not have a special case
for sequence that sequence should be
just like the general case so you'd see
sequence of thought there no I don't
agree with that yeah and not as I only
don't agree with that because that's
what people are going to ionize some
options in a function they need to see
this well well you could argue that if
it started with a head then keep the
head but if it started it's just a you
know a list of items then you don't
inject that head name that's correct
okay but because list of my color this
case come on nobody knows about
okay this case if I recognize that they
just want to see dot dot that they sure
as hell don't want to see sequence open
bracket yeah right but but that is what
they have there oh no doubt no doubt
which I'll complete will actually affect
the valuation all right fine they still
don't want to see those words there yeah
they want to see dot dot dot I mean if I
only the only thing I wonder is whether
they might want to see something like
you know comma dot dot dot comma dot or
something like that that indicates up to
a small number of items how many items
there are anybody think that's useful no
no okay very good thank you
right I mean if you maybe want the icon
to just be actually looks like the
sequence but would the number of dots
being the number of items up to a limit
would be interesting to - I don't think
so yeah I think that's totally obscure I
mean if it was going to be something
like this what I would do here is to
have some gray blob in the middle here
right so so it's a you know glaucoma
glaucoma bra up to like three or four of
them I think I think the main
distinction that we care about and which
we're already doing is one item versus
more than one item okay but in the more
than one item do you think the doctor
talk gets that across I'd you think that
would be better got across as a bunch of
comic you're right you're right I'm I'm
I'm capitulating on this SEO I think
you're right it should just be dot out
dot can we talk about the okay
I don't think do we really think this is
you
full Association array well I guess it
does no harm okay with respect to this
kind of list thing does anybody think
it's useful to have this certainly
having just the total number of elements
no I mean maybe the dimensions although
obviously for a higher rank or even just
a large low dimensional array that can
be quite big yeah let's skip it seem
that information is in the opener view
sure in the opened right in the in the
array case what is that even saying is
that one one row is that many items or
total I don't know I I think Billy
wasn't clear okay all right yeah that
was supposed to be the total number of
elements in the array okay you know it
does I think irrelevant now this
association array case are we really
distinguishing that case I mean it's
significant to functions like data set I
mean they don't know no I don't know if
it's very significant beyond that well I
guess transpose if you tried the
transpose it will yeah I think this is
an unusual case but but what happens if
it's like a list of associations or
something we're not indicating that it's
just a list as far as this is concerned
right I mean I would prefer to just have
you know the outer head be represented
and I kind of would - I think this one
is is unclear it suggests that there's
only I mean first of all it suggests
it's a depth 2 thing second of all it
suggests to Tony - yeah let's just skip
it let's just have yeah I also worry
about the typesetting efficiency issues
when you're typesetting associations to
recognize that's I mean it might be a
long step to figure out if it's an
association or a I see so let's not do
it let's just have the overall head okay
final thing the icon for data set
that's that is a new one the old one
looked more like a calendar but we're
still a little iffy here
what about something that's more like a
you know a spreadsheet looking array
type thing just a pure grid that
obviously silly I don't know what this
reminds me of this dataset thing but it
I don't think it reminds me of a data
set
okay cut comments from people I mean
well I yes well I guess I can see how
that's also being data set but I suppose
if I started just on its own I guess I
would think it's a table but I don't
know how you distinguish between the
table and the data set or a grid for
example right spreadsheet I mean or
should we just have the data set had to
be there now maybe we just allow data
set to be in the general case
I mean data set has its own opening
closing shrinking so I think it's less
like you're less likely to ionize it
that's true
let's okay for now let's just put it in
the in the general population okay I
like this turtle Association sorry go
ahead right so that thing which you were
about to say that you liked what was
going to be another question you know
should should we force the style on the
user should we allow the user to make
their own style for the name I think we
should default to italic if they put
their own style then well what would
happen I mean John I mean it's a mixin
type thing right so the the italic is
mixed in if they also said bold then
they get that as well if they also said
red they get that as well yeah so I
think it's fine
it just is adding the italic style to it
no they put in bold and then it flows
through we don't we don't block the bold
but we also don't add the bold okay okay
I think we're great here I have one
suggestion but feel free to shoot this
down I wonder if as a special case
of sequence we want something that
detects a sequence of rule and Rolaids
which would typically be a sequence of
options
what would we recognize it as I don't
know I mean I think it would be cool to
be able to say options to be able to say
something like you know paren options
italic that would be cool how cool do
people think that is I mean let's say
it's a plot for example and and
particularly keeping in mind that in a
you know future version of you know
examples and the documentation might see
there's quite a lot yes right we were
thinking we we should add a button to
docq tools that are thematically added
the name options I mean my worried about
sort of doing this in the generic case
is that right we don't really know
whether it's options well we actually do
if we know what function it for the head
if we know the head if we look at the
head when we do the organization then we
do know what it is usually not always
look if we don't know it we don't say it
but if we do know what we could say it
between the keyboard shortcut and the
function right there's the function the
function I can I certainly wouldn't have
any notes in those that's correct but
the function is just a is a context-free
you know context independent icon
ization I mean there's just a
convenience right I mean it's just
there's no there's no guarantee you have
contexts in the interactive version
either I mean you probably do but
absolutely no guarantee well fair enough
I mean look putting it in docu tools is
a good start but I mean I think um well
I guess we can play with it I mean I
if the interactive version can figure it
out I think it would be a nice thing to
do but don't get it wrong
I mean don't start saying that an
arbitrary list of rules is options I
only do it when it's in the options
position of a function and so yeah the
other possibility would be to find some
design that doesn't communicate options
but communicates rules I don't remember
doing
for this yet or yeah shift control I
which has not been vetted
I sort of scrounged up keys that were
available okay anybody object to it I
would need to do a little bit of
research to before I lodge an objection
or accept it okay um I see right and for
example and certainly with my layouts
right where I have applications
Mathematica eleven point you know 4.0
you know debugs dot app that can be
quite a jump
well we could wrap it and we could wrap
the lines we could insist the lines
don't go wider that maybe mister yeah on
Mac and Windows control shift tires
convert to info form control shift IO
come on shift I Mac sorry sorry I
misspoke Windows and Linux Windows and
Linux just convert info form okay that's
not good but we don't need to decide
here I can I can sit down with Lou and
we can come up with a proposal it's I
don't want to waste all right okay fine
um this is a cool feature really a cool
feature um okay let me see that
everything for this assuming we're not
let's not do the the options fanciness
for right now I mean unless to be
explored but not um understood
okay right I mean I guess does my
example give you any pause about
left/right opener or are we okay with
summary boxes at least in the short form
being different from mine cognizing even
revisit jeremy do you have any bright
ideas here I definitely like this for I
can eyes i torn on what to do with the
summary blobs don't like what I see but
I don't have a solution that doesn't
jump the kind that actually where the
always visible things I mean there are
probably multiple examples but maybe I
should do an inventory before we make
any sort of decision okay fine you know
they're not super common but it's not
like this is the only example and you
may think something like like one of the
socket objects I think like it shows one
thing like no I mean we may be able to
redesign it so it wraps instead of
jumping where you could just have name
and full name and the full name it's
down below just down below mm-hmm as a
sort of baseline could we at least
update the icon to use the new smaller
gray asset sure oh yeah that's true well
I guess I should defer to Lucas but I
think that's trivial I think that'll
definitely help so the all the designs
that we're looking at the the actual
active target area would be the same
right it's not like growing to the right
or something in terms of you know if you
click no what you hit like what you can
hit you're saying in this case if you
hit in this area here does it do
anything what you have to hit the minus
sign yeah I think you have to hit the
minus sign plus some padding you know
right I wonder if we want like the
limiters around it just to sort of make
it clear that it's not an infinitely
wide well so there is some ambiguity and
the ambiguity would be helped by just a
mouse over visual yeah I think it should
light up on hawa mm-hmm do we understand
how this works on a touch interface
I think there's probably not any thing
to worry about on a touch interface okay
I think yeah but all the actual actions
are normal flex so we know that okay
well good um alright I think that's that
for the first item here um can I raise
something while we're at it the the the
standardization of loading icons I'm you
know I like this blue for those or
something close to that blue for these
loading icons I wasn't that keen on the
darker blue for the that somehow
appeared in the machine learning loading
icons I I just for this version all I'm
expecting is that the height and color
of the loading icons be standardized but
I just want to clarify what we're
standardizing to right Billy and Jeremy
are you aware of what the UM assets are
for that no it's been a while we agreed
to that a little fella can pull it up I
saw the ticket recently I haven't had a
chance to pull up the older designs let
me go hunt him down but there was never
more than one design and I think we
settled it so it'll sound like a bug
maybe well I don't know but I mean I'm
telling you that the the height look I
don't know whether I can do this but
let's say net model of I don't know what
let's let's guess that this isn't um
okay so now what we should see here
whenever it wakes up whatever it's doing
I don't know what it's doing
oh gosh um okay let me pick up another
one I'm just going to pick around them
we need a new function I'm sorry okay
they see that
well actually that's a reasonable blue
which version is this now this is the
current version I also just emailed the
last sort of design iteration we had
okay but this is also by the way it
should say downloading from repository
or downloading content from repository
the word thee should not be there and
this is a different go ahead the text
here is it is in blue and well Jeremy or
anybody else do you want a pine on that
I'm not a huge fan of the blue text but
Billy that's what you expect here or not
yes do you like it or would you prefer
gray text I think we liked the blue with
the the dark blue text with the blue box
but if it were great it would look fine
as well long as it's darker than the
line below yep okay um okay well so
could we just see a version of this with
grey yeah
and and what what what's the older
drinking well I guess we're waiting for
that download to finish but then can you
give us an input that words so if you
did something like any prefetch of
element you'd get the download monitor
it is you guys'll try that yeah I really
I prefer that gray it you're talking
about the text or not the background yes
yeah we should old old background gray
we updated pretty much everything that
I'm aware of downloads to use the right
so this one here it's just we haven't
standardized properly the names and so
on and this is hi this is taller be nice
to stand as the height not as important
I just think the color and the color
should be standardized okay
is it easy to grab the color from that
code Nick yeah I can I can sing it to
you but there's a there's a kernel
function that basically just defines
what grabs from that type that style
okay okay and that over and then I could
put it in and then send it on out okay
there's a lot of
that's really good I uh you know this is
low looking good okay um related topic
here is information so is this also a
design question yes very much so
[Music]
okay so these are examples of
information suggestion well I think it
would be helpful if Lou and Jon stated
it right so this is the design for the
multi symbol
okay so we're losing the light printer
paper yeah maybe I have to or obvious we
have columns instead of rows it's just
the way it's it's alphabetized okay
until we once alphabetized by by column
guessing it's multi column which applies
to that way yeah okay fine fine um yeah
I I think the line printer paper was was
good in the 80s that color scheme is you
know like it's less old than my time
here because I remember when we that we
changed this maybe about five years ago
yeah I agree with you yes um I think it
might have been green at some point no
I'm joking
um okay let me lay out what the issue
remaining issues are one yes one is what
does the multi look like and how does it
behave when you click on it the other is
right so we have in the old information
has question mark in double question
mark which are differ by an option right
it's long and long calendar and so the
quest so first of all we need to decide
what exactly that means in the new world
is that just a different state of the
theme or is it actually a different
different thing and this
to decide does that only apply to
symbols or just apply anything that and
you can well one question is
syntactically I don't even know what a
pre question mark does I mean in other
words is it the case that you could say
question mark file here no okay so the
question mark binding question mark
binding necessarily stringify is its
argument but it does parse like it needs
to have a full form and it parses to
information of abstract and with either
Longo's to or false okay so question
here this question mark thing is a
beginning of line escape effectively
right yes I mean was back from back in
the day of totally I mean that is the
way the front end treats it fine
so one thing that beginning of line
escapes do in the modern world is they
go into a different you know input style
right so like if I do a greater than
sign or if I do you know all our various
beginning of line escapes now well I
mean this is this is in the language
it's not like what you're talking about
which is extra language yeah I
understand but it is going to stringify
I mean I'm just saying if we wanted to
we could present it as a you know an
active you know something which does
something on him you know which
immediately does something to the input
I don't know what we cap we maybe don't
care there is one problem with that it
might not be a serious problem but is
that it's not just question mark at the
beginning of a cell is question mark at
the beginning of a line which may be a
fiying that's horrifying and look that
functionality is fine to support in the
terminal version you know along with
shell escapes at arbitrary lines but I
have to say I think that
has you know gone the way of the what's
a good 1980s thing well I mean bang has
what in the middle of a we're not
supporting that anymore exactly that's
that's an example something that has
gone the way of whatever you were gonna
say no I was going to refer to some
popular culture thing just to prove
anyway right I mean except people do I
mean certainly people create multiple
input cells and write each one of those
inputs is trans descent individually to
the kernel so it's not like there's a
huge difference between that right if
you if you do touching mark foo and then
enter and then whatever other expression
you want so those will be sent as two
individual and there will be two
separate mapping falls to the front end
even if they're in the same cell from
the front end to the kernel you mean yes
yeah is the front then in this case here
yes the front end will notice that
there's one complete expression and by
the way notice the bug of that weird
internal backtick symbol information
well that's specific to the prototype
bill that's something I don't care
fixing I just haven't pushed an update
yeah I don't understand what we want
here I mean that the fact that this
thing works intermediate to in an
intermediate part of an input seems
unbelievably surplus to requirements in
the post 1980s well I mean we're not
actually arguing that the point is that
those are even though they're in the
same cell they're two inputs okay but I
don't know some why we should support
this at all I think it should just be at
the beginning of their blind not making
a strong argument that we should I'm
just pointing out that it is something
that will break if we do this what's
something that will break
you know input cells well you know
dealing with input cells that have you
know embedded question mark or question
mark question mark you know as a new
line and there it you know or or you
know as the first line but then followed
by legitimate inputs in suit you saying
I see what you're saying do we think
that's a documented feature from the
notebook front end it was documented me
is it's certainly documented that you
can feed multiple inputs into a single
cell and well special input form an
operator and all right okay fine so
let's assume you can do this I don't
know how that affects what we're talking
about here particular let's let's go
look at the so you're just attacking my
idea that the question mark should be
should jump into some kind of weird
special basically I'm saying that
question question mark an equal is a
false equivalence I'm not saying that
your idea is entirely bad I'm just
saying that declaring that is good
because the equivalence is a bad
argument right but so the question is
could we enhance the role you know the
behavior of question mark in some
interesting way if we were to go into a
different mode I mean we could for
example we could put an autocomplete on
it which would be nice does it yeah yeah
okay well
fair enough okay um right I mean the
real question we need to answer is you
know are so right so to compare you know
dude question mark plot and then
question mark question mark quad which
should give you the exhibit oh this is
already giving you a new yeah and the
prototype they behave the same way right
so I guess we need a non prototype bill
to see how those two guys compare and
then the question is are those two
different views on you know to the right
does this also become a guy with you
know movable views or does that become
or are these in fact two different
evaluated results look my initial take
would be question mark question mark
just is the version of this where that
bottom panel is open and you know there
might be a plus sign or something like
that to open this bottom panel which
will be absent in the pure you know in
this pure case and in the single
question mark case that would be my
initial take no I don't I'm not sure I
understand that what I'm saying with it
with it with just some opener for the
rest of it whereas with yo whereas with
a little muted opener whereas in the
double question mark case it would have
that second panel open by default okay
and this will be special two symbols
that's what I'm thinking yes okay all
right let's take a look at the designs
that you have over here I mean I think
um this built-in symbol is awfully heavy
and I'm worrying that these that these
definitions here should be wouldn't it
be nicer if those definitions like we do
in the case of if I do this see those
definitions have separators around them
I understand that here I think there's
too much space there isn't that isn't
that matching the documentation it's
close at least yeah but I think that
just visually there's too much space
between the the template line and the
explanation this could be more compact
but I think that this is too compact
mm-hmm
could you pull up did Heidi her and I
talked through a version I don't know if
that was part of what you were sent but
we wanted to let to make the function
head a little heavier the text of a
lighter which would help in here yeah I
understand why that has to be on a
single line I mean I think that doesn't
really help anything compactness yeah
right and obviously for something try
something like question mark D which has
long usage lines I'm curious if the line
break worth it just becomes very yeah mm
not very long
oh those aren't as long as I thought
they would be what about discrete limit
maybe right so there it becomes very
just very wide well what happens if my
notebook is less wide let me point out
victory lap that um several problems
here first of all it's very hard to
distinguish the template from the rest
because the font is the same second of
all obviously the spacing here is a
little bit funky because the spacing
here got closer between those two than
it is given the built up math here yeah
I think we definitely need some extra
space even if we're on a single line I
think we need some extra space between
usages right and you can see D which was
not very long as now also line broke yes
well it looks beautiful
um this thing about putting the
attributes first just seems awfully
pedantic let's put the options first for
goodness sake let's put the attributes
down I mean I would think that it should
go symbol name and context at the bottom
I mean symbol name do well I guess I
guess there could be a case where it's
an in you know it's like a plus sign or
something but that seems awfully obscure
yeah I mean you can't do like question
mark slash add for map since yeah yeah
okay well if it's possible to display
symbol name in the case where there is a
non-trivial symbol name mapping but in
the other cases it's just just
incredibly pedantic I don't see the
point at all um
documentation links I think that those
should be visually correspond to those
eye things that you see in the raft
documentation or you're just suggesting
that you should add we should add
iconography to match I'm suggesting
adding iconography and maybe the eye for
local and something else for the web I
don't know and I wouldn't say
documentation links I would just say
documentation okay um but we really need
to move those attributes down because
they are really obscure and presumably
when the thing has down values that will
appear here as well right yeah well as
long as it's not read protected I've
been playing with this and just now
because I really hadn't seen this
feature before today and I can't say
that I'm very happy with what's been
done as a result it's now showing things
as a list of hold patterns which is
considerably less useful if you're
trying to tweak things I think it's it's
showing this whole pattern what I'm used
to when I'm exploring something like
this is being able to I mean you know it
has the literal colon equal so I can
copy/paste tweak and evaluates yes
that's what we want and the fact that
it's got an ex collar there is crazy
crazy
well that's no I understand but it's
wrong well yeah well I mean that is my
big use for this my big use for this
isn't to look at something is to change
something you know where I maybe don't
have the original code but I can you
know go digging for the code I think
what we should say is we should call
this definitions because I think the
down value thing is unbelievably tight
and I think they should say F of 1
equals f of X plain colon equals blah
blah blah right well what happens if we
also have values and values like I think
what happens now I don't have a
convenient example here but I mean don't
we do the right thing showing you know
carat colony core or whatever don't we
do that right now it's separated by we
basically look specifically for down
value lists or the down values the up
values sorry right now I mean what we do
like an 11-3 um I just do here I have to
I have to not have a down value
um just add another argument to F right
yeah this is utterly obscure up value
transformations with smooshed words and
down value with it with um you know
multi words that's crazy
this should just say this should be
called definitions I think and this
could be called up values because
anybody who understands you know look it
could be called definitions and then
maybe up value definitions and they're
making sense yeah and so salary
definitions if we have those so one
thing we don't I think we don't
currently show which my right I mean we
have other we have other kinds of values
that we don't necessarily currently show
and maybe we shouldn't others and so on
like yes format value
we should show these
right and I guess the question well so
maybe we should I know maybe it's useful
to sort of mush up down I don't think I
don't think we should mush smushed him I
think we should have them as separate I
think we should have definitions look I
think we should say we should say we
should save value for the own value then
we should say definitions for the down
values then we should say up value
definitions I kind of guess that because
it's about you definitions etc format
definitions blah blah blah then we have
definitions and all the other ones for
what it's worth
historically we've always thrown values
first I don't know if there is good
reason for that or if that's arbitrary
yeah but I think that's utterly obscure
I think that people I don't forget
matters because I think most things will
either have up values or I think this is
fine why not just you know skip guys
which are empty and of course and if
they're both down values enough values I
think we should stick up values first
because those are applied first then
that makes sense then for people right
people are used to reading them what are
you saying I'm sorry sorry say that
again what are you guys saying basically
we should list the definitions in the
order that they're applied and since I
value definitions are always applied
first if they're there then we should
list them first okay but it's going to
be very obscure if you see up by
definitions and then I mean if you have
up value
and down value definitions it's always
obscure to a certain degree but I think
we okay so then what I think we should
be listen yeah okay fine okay then my
proposal will be if there is an up-bow
definitions then say explicitly down
value definitions if there is no value
then just say definitions but still
putting up value flap but but still put
it first that's gotta change
no I understand okay so there if the up
values is present then putting them
first if they're not then am it down
value from the key of the next one by
the way this should say value or delayed
value right because there can also be
the colon equals case and that will not
be visible here unless we say unless we
write out for value x equals blah blah
blah which should we do should be bright
out value as x equals or should we an x
colon equals or should we have value and
delayed value well traditionally we use
the equal and follow me for and and once
again well let's see I guess I selected
fine if we have the equal in the colon
equal once again we lend ourselves to
making it a bit easier to copy patient
week
all right okay fine is this gonna have
click to copy why don't we make click to
copy for these things
I I think I think having if I clicked a
copy you mean having you know a trivial
copy button is good but there might be
cases where someone wants to actually
click inside to get a piece of it as
well and I don't think we should deny
that yeah so long as the selection is
easy to make for the
well I mean you can just have a button
that trivially you know throws the whole
thing on the clipboard and that would be
awesome okay but as a the whole thing
all the definition no no for each
definition so there would be a button
for each definition or right okay can we
loop back to one thing here about values
what are we gonna call this so we're
gonna say value and then it's gonna say
x equals it's a little weird to do that
isn't it
or we could call it definition but then
that conflicts with the down value
definitions when there's no down value
right um
assignment what do you think works for
me not obviously ridiculous to me okay
okay
okay all right so can we look back here
to what we're doing with the rest of
this so okay so we're going to figure
out a better formatting for these things
here that is more in line with what
happens with the raft make sense we're
going to figure out a way to plus a Phi
for the case of single question mark
to indicate that there's more down here
whether it's a plus sign of Willem a
type thing I don't know what it is I'm
not wild about the way it says built-in
symbol at the top and I mean these are
very heavy these headers it's like you
don't say I mean you know what I'm
saying I mean I think could we try to
make those thinner like half height and
somehow Jeremy do you have an idea for
what to do with those not not have
height so they're just not that
important maybe they could be lighter we
could make the type a little lighter if
it's yeah I think a little tag lozenge
that says oh so it's not full width it's
just a little thing yeah what do you
mean it'd be like left aligned and only
the width of the text what would be the
first line yeah tab bar so if you go to
like anything on in documentation
there's a little tab on the top what
what do you mean what do you mean by
anything in documentation you mean just
to see like an example oh I see I see I
suit you're saying so you're saying if I
go to this and I go to for example cloud
object you're saying that thing there is
that right or something like it yeah
okay and but then that then the vertical
them then at the top we've got something
where most of what's there is blank
right the top yeah thing yeah you look
weird but look this is way too heavy
okay I mean it's like you don't say you
asked for information on a thing it's
like yeah I know it's a cloud object cuz
I just saw it was a cloud object
okay what I'm saying I'm wondering about
the parentheticals like we have four
entities
you mean to just say after this name
you know like gray cloud objects / n
cloud object here yes
Danette for the print you have your
opener or whatever what open up well the
plus to expand in the symbol case yeah I
mean I look I think in the symbol case
repeating the name of the symbol at the
top seems like a decent thing to do
saying built-in symbol seems very
surplus to requirements I mean it well
know is it's useful to say that but okay
let's try and mock up something where
the main event is you know this name
here
and I don't think in the case of an
entity with a special color we don't
even need to say entity I'm making sense
it's only in the case well I mean this
is going to be utterly weird some cases
where there's not an obvious for data
been I mean I don't think putting the
bin Association as the header would be
super obvious or the UUID or what about
this thing the short ID that's what I
would expect paren data been hmm
or this thing bran cloud object could
you scroll down look at date and file
they just seem weird if we apply it out
there
you do print data object next to this
string form
hmm.well dates dates obviously have
their own iconography which by the way I
think is overly heavy mm-hmm and I would
like to see a redesign of that I don't
think it dates really need to be quite
so bold okay and I don't think I mean we
could we should try some things d
building them slightly I mean if we have
a demi bold or something that would be
the best maybe I'm not sure okay but but
over here um look we could try keeping
the thing as you have it except that in
the case of this we really have got to
say the name of the symbol somewhere at
the top it's kind of crazy to not do
that well yeah and maybe it isn't look
why don't we just try to save what we
have here but just make that top bar
much less prominent yeah okay um okay
with respect to these Multi multi things
I mean I don't really
and what the formatting of this this
seems very heavy this this in modern
times to have I don't know
I mean so what's the question here is
this no it's a right so the question is
so right now we have the appearance that
you see less and the question is what
should and if we're moving away from you
know dot matrix paper then what a what
should it look like and it's not shown
here what should the action be when you
click on it and I think actually I think
we decided last time that it should be
basically the same it should spawn a new
cell that I think so yeah I think so
right so then I guess the question is
the look of this yeah and I have no
strong opinion I mean I think I leave I
mean Jeremy Billy what do you think I
don't see your mouth moving Steven
you're looking at the sister yeah this
stuff yeah I was happy with where we
ended up here it's nice and simple and
clean not too ornate okay what about the
way the the contexts work are we happy
with that and these things seem awfully
heavy
so they could be a lighter gray could
they match the openers for will be using
the headers when making cells group cell
groupings
the chevron that turns sorry said that
again what the the new cell group
openers yes you're talking about the
right-hand cell openers the chevron but
they're not normally there when it's
open they usually a side effect of
closing
and I think we want the explicit openers
especially some right and you want
people to know that they can close these
yes because they may get very very long
right if you want to grade down or
unfold the context I don't have any
objection to that I do have one question
for Lou which is at the present time are
we fixed at two farms or is it
dynamically how is the number of columns
the information code looks at the width
of your notebook and then the width of
the strings that come back and decides
how many columns to display based on
those things um okay um let's okay I
just want to okay so I think we're in
good shape on most of the stuff um we
have a number of interesting comments
from our live stream which I just want
to go through here um let's see
somebody's asking does that mean format
values and subs will be documented are
they not documented now we never
documented them I have no problem with
documenting them I think it I think
it'll basically be a matter of switching
from internal to normal and then maybe
having a few examples all right that
that's a separate discussion let's put
that back on the LCC agenda for another
time
someone is pointing out um a nifty
feature for reading code might be to add
a key shortcut to show the information
panel is an attached self or symbols
currently under the mouse
I think there's something to that idea
not necessarily exactly in the way it's
described but I think there's something
to that idea that could be interesting
right I mean there's the other thing
that we've had which we probably should
provide for users in a more convenient
way is the thing that we built for the
course authoring tools where the thing
displays that right-hand key you know
what I'm talking about
no I don't think I do here let me show
you for one second um let's see where is
it course were tools how do I know of
course well how do i how I start anew oh
yeah of course lecture there we go okay
so let's say I've got this course
lecture here and I say generate
recording configuration okay okay that's
my transcript
controls okay where is it so what I want
to do now okay that's my that is just a
trademark Steven Bazaar palette there
which one I can i Steven this would be
the icon yeah pretty much
okay so here look see now it went
advanced to begin and now I say gosh I
can't even know how this works slow
tight
yeah there we go so then okay so see
that so this is the recording area of my
screen right and people have you been
using this for our MOOCs alright so if I
go is this okay
I mean it's interesting I think I think
that's interesting for for example in
presenter tools I think that's an
interesting thing well but this is this
is a very presentation oriented sort of
thing others not even look what is it
doing that you know I don't I would have
to guess it it may be some form of
overlay or attach so this going on here
I really need to distribute these course
authoring tools by the way they really
work quite nicely and people should be
using them yeah based on the shadow I
think that it's not a separate window
I think it's inside the notebook and and
created how well is so we've long had a
way to to basically overlay something on
top of an entire notebook even before we
had attached cells we had a mechanism at
Te'o added it to support some
drag-and-drop stuff and it wouldn't be
surprised if this is
using either that or the attached cell
mechanism okay okay hey point for Sushma
we can can you remind Andre that we
really need to package this stuff soap
so we can distribute it um okay but
anyway do we think that there's any
value to something like this for you you
think this is very special case to what
the way I think what we're seeing here
is very much presentation oriented I
whereas the way I interpret the the
comment is you know that it might not
just be about presentation but it might
be you know I don't know exploration
interface right so I yeah yeah yeah in
line presents the values yes it's a good
idea right
I think visual studio actually has
something very similar where instead of
go to definition
it's kind of an attached interface where
it shows the definition you know right
where you're at so you can see the code
you were looking at and the definition
side-by-side and you can even then go
and explore multiple definitions and it
shows them in kind of a tab view right
so lifestream is pointing out that
command shift K should be somehow
automatic yeah this is a separate topic
we should put this into the user
assistants discussion but that's fine
that's fine and in that context I can
demo the visual studio feature I'm
talking about to you I think okay how
this comments on the livestream
up values are not really applied before
down values up rows of arguments are
applied before down values at the head
it's all true um but down values the
arguments are applied before all that
yes that's true but this is saying for a
particular head F yeah we're not seeing
the definitions for everything we're
seeing the definitions for one thing
right
let's see suggestion to use the the
style that we have for external
languages somehow here in commenting
that the top grade bar makes it looked
like something from the 1990s okay well
we at least advanced from the 1980s
there
I don't know do we want to go to any
color here III doesn't I mean I think if
this were two thousand teens color
scheme it might be white
I mean people seem to be very keen on
white and flat these days I'm not sure
that's useful leave it to the design
group to decide I mean they're going to
they're gonna you know move that color
down anyway yeah um okay I think we have
to wrap here in just a moment um yeah
this is a completely different
discussion this register catch thing is
an utterly different discussion quite
interesting but but artfully different
this caching as opposed to suppressing
repeated error messages that is going to
be another one of these design meets you
know graphic design meets um what an
earth is all of this well anyway I think
this is for another time
yeah all right I think that's it for
today I think okay thanks everybody
thanks to folks on the livestream
appreciate the comments see y'all soon